welcome to this video its jet set TFS
this is a Swiss flexor might as well
pronounce it in in German okay okay
let's just play some normal development
moves and fianchetto everything that we
have now okay he's also doing that hmm
yeah maybe I should play more exciting
openings that really is not very very
interesting and you know what he plays
exactly that I play that Quincy seven
runs in 2 95 and so should be avoided
no I can can do that go to be seven yeah
the good thing about this position it is
very solid the bad thing about it is
yeah it is very solid it's nothing ever
happening you just trade some stuff now
yeah this my TM is always slightly
annoying to fight try to push b5 to
undermine the support of this piece
maybe you can you can do something with
Queen D for Queen 87 but this is ok it's
not not trying that mm now
it's not it's not that easy here it's
not that easy
it's definitely a slight pressure here
on blacks position is threatening to
take and play 97
if I take myself that's also not easy
hmm I don't see a good move to be honest
at the moment I don't see a good move at
all
surprising
yes specially 97's I really annoying may
you have to have the night somewhere and
he's threatening night c7 now wow I
really don't see I mean this is this is
terrible for black but I really don't
know why it was so terrible amazing
yeah maybe even rook rook c7 as puzzle
so many good really good moves yeah
that's one of them Knight b6 Knight f6
any of those moves right f6 you will
take you just just just terrible just
terribly bad
I mean at least he has some chances to
blunder like windy 45 looks like a
blunder I can take now here if I take on
seven let's do this hope that somehow my
queen is giving me come to play with
Queenie 124 in case of a capture on d6
and that's that actually is a draw I
think
hmm maybe the the worst the worst is
over after something like a fall though
he still chat yeah I have to go for the
checks wait for just a moment yeah well
I karameesh I can only draw anyway at
best can give this check take on what
the chat is it is also just a shell you
can try to go to f1 then I will just
check right well that was lucky it was a
really bad position somehow here I mean
I didn't see a move okay at least the
computer doesn't it doesn't see what as
well Queen baf is the best defense but
it is just just a crappy position this
is here here he somehow lets it slip mmm
this is this is not enough how can he
rook c6 yeah that's that's not bad yeah
Quincy free and possibly Roxy 7 yeah I'm
totally boxed in what does this mean
probably that be five is really not good
yeah i mean i was thinking that be five
is not a bad idea but okay you know it
is not a bad idea but i have to take
here and then play this that is much
better now that's much better yeah due
to various reasons if we compare here my
here my king is on g7 vulnerable to
checks and he is actually able to play
rook see one if i take first oops take
first this is much stronger if he now
takes and I capture here the move Roxy
one is really totally pointless because
I can capture and rook takes blunders
this night so this was the key to the
position after be five I have a decent
game he can take and we continue from
there but he does not have Roxy one end
without Luke see one he basically has no
useful movie ax he can only play slow
moves and after that I have a good
chance to see I can't even think about a
65 if he allows it yeah that was the
problem ok good to understand I was
really thinking about what was exactly
the mistake but it was the move order
really here I'm here i am in huge
trouble all of the Sun ok well thanks
for watching